[موسيقى]
زجاج المورانو ناعم جدًا ، أليس كذلك؟
ضع هذا الزجاج على طرف مكواة قطة الكي ، ثم ضعها وأدرها
هل تريد تشكيله؟
لهذا السبب ، ولكن على أي حال ، إذا لم تفعل ذلك بسرعة ، فسوف يسقط أو يسقط بسبب الجاذبية.
نظرًا لأنه يتدفق ويتدفق ، سأقوم بتشكيله أثناء الإحماء والقيام بشيء مثل 5 مدارس.
أنا Marifu 3 أنا فنان زجاج
[موسيقى]
ويب كاس اليابانية rs أسبوعين إندر
مكتب إندر إندر ، بو دو دو
فتائل كأس بلوم آسا ليدز كما
لقاء لمارك فيينا اسبانيا كلاس
كنت في البندقية منذ حوالي 30 عامًا
كنت أبحث عن فرصة ، لكني لم أجد أرجوحة الزهرة المنفردة.
حسنًا ، قال صديقي إنه يجب أن يحاول القيام بذلك بنفسه في ذلك الوقت.
الذهاب من خلال الهجوم والدفاع عن تلك القرية
كفنان زجاج ، هكذا بدأت
أنا ناشط
الويب للقيام به
دوزيلتيك بيرسو إيرث فيينا برينو
Propipe
nx pen wat مع فريق Waywood Working Scene
تجميد
[موسيقى]
يصبح الشعور بالجلد مثل مدير المعهد الموسيقي والأوركسترا واحدًا
أعتقد أنني أستطيع أن أفعل أكثر مما كنت أعتقد
غالبًا ما ألهمني الطبيعة ، لذلك أنا هنا دائمًا
أعتقد أنه قد يتأثر بانعكاس الماء لأنني أمشي قطة.
قل هيون
شخصيًا ، هناك مكان مثل بلد أحبه ، ومن الجميل رؤية ما ينعكس.
هذا كيف أنها مرتبطة وآه
شعور
[موسيقى]
نظرًا لأن المفهوم هو Carry ، فلنسمه مخطط الضوء.
عندما تكون ممتلئة ، حان الوقت لإلقاء نظرة على الشخص الذي يراها ، مثل نافذة صوت القلب.
أريدك أن تكون
[موسيقى]